[Musique]
la planète surchauffe une forêt brûlent
des rivières débordent autant s'y
habituer ce genre d'événements extrêmes
qui avant avait lieu au 50 ans
reviennent désormais tous les dix ans et
si rien n'est fait ça pourrait être
chaque année
c'est un des avertissements lancés par
le groupe d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat le chiac leur
sixième rapport publié en ou tranche
avec les précédents à bien des égards la
première différence est dans ton
au fil du temps les chercheurs ont testé
puis écartée différentes hypothèses sur
les causes du réchauffement le gie axa
puis sont 14 mais l'étude aujourd'hui il
affirme que c'est sans équivoque
l'activité humaine qui réchauffe
l'atmosphère les océans et des
continents le mercure a déjà grimpé d'un
degré la question c'est de savoir où ça
va s'arrêter
c'est un petit marteau mais je pense
qu'il peut faire de grandes choses
en 2015 à paris l'objectif était de
garder l'échauffement bien en dessous de
deux degrés et idéalement à 1,5 degré le
rapport du giec c'est un peu comme un
bulletin scolaire que les scientifiques
remettent aux politiciens et les notes
ne sont pas très bonnes
il n'y a qu'une autre scénario le plus
optimiste qu'on serait sous la cible
d'un verre qu'une 5 degrés
d'augmentation à la fin du siècle pour
cela il faut en une génération
revoir complètement notre façon de vivre
mais si l'humanité poursuit sur sa
lancée actuelle le réchauffement
atteindrait 2 7 degrés à la fin du
siècle et sur l'appui son accélérateur
on parle de 4 ou même presque 2,5 degrés
les conséquences seraient désastreuses
particulièrement au canada
le rapport du giec inclut pour la
première fois des projections régionales
dans les données qu'on récolte on voit
déjà que le canada s'est réchauffée plus
vite que la moyenne du globe à mesure
que le mercure va grimper on s'attend ce
que la différence s'accentue
c'est entre autres parce que les
continents se réchauffe plus vite que
les océans mais aussi parce qu'avec la
chaleur la glace et la neige fond ou
plutôt on réfléchit donc moins la
lumière du soleil résultat le
réchauffement accélère le réchauffement
cette hausse de température est liée à
la quantité totale de gaz à effet de
serre accumulées et le giec utilise une
image intéressante celle d'un budget à
respecter pour rester sous la cible d'un
25 degrés le problème c'est que depuis
l'ère industrielle
on a déjà dépensé 85 % de ce budget de
grs il en reste donc 15 % l'équivalent
de dix ans des missions au rythme actuel
c'est ce 15% qui sera sur la table lors
de la conférence de glasgow en novembre
prochain et quelques 200 pays vont
tenter de se partager avec ce sixième
rapport du giec la science par but
clairement jamais et plus jamais ce sera
aux politiciens d'agir
[Musique]